what's going on guys summer movie season
is heating up and we've already seen so
many epic things
Avengers earthquakes dinosaurs a dude
playing an electric guitar that shoots
fire on top of a car turtle and it's
still June with so many a-list stars
slaying the box office it's easy to
forget that they all had humble
beginnings that's why we're here to
bring you before they were famous summer
2015 edition let's start her off with
the movie that kicked off summer 2015
Avengers age of Ultron first up Thor
himself
Chris Hemsworth here he is in 2002 about
50 pounds lighter and three octaves
higher and Australia's longest-running
drama series neighbours we've been
robbed in what but just now oh why don't
you press the alarm on the dish I don't
know I just did I was just she freaked
out you know I just didn't think yeah
police let's also give some love to
another underappreciated Avenger
Hawkeye played by Jeremy Renner now
before he was blasting fools with arrows
and hanging out with his wife and kids
on a farm he was doing his best Bill and
Ted impression in 1995 cinematic classic
National Lampoon's senior trip I'm
concerned about you Lisa you're gonna
wake up one day and realize that you
wasted all of your high school years
studying and you're gonna wake up and
realize you're a loser let's talk Mad
Max fury road it's blowing mines and
racking up the box office
led by tough guy superstar Tom Hardy
don't let that manly facade fool you
inside he's really a soft as evidenced
by this UK Kleenex advertisement
[Music]
fun fact the movie was watching on
television Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome
Master Blaster runs Bartertown
can't forget Charlize Theron burning up
the screen in Mad Max as furiosa max's
badass one-armed traveling companion
here's Charlize in a very revealing
martini commercial from the 90s
[Music]
charli's witness me the Pibb jeremy
piven he and the boys from Entourage are
on the big screen this summer but Piven
has been around um forever
lest we forget he was faked sitcom
George on Seinfeld before he discovered
some kind of magical let's just say it
pair plugs and back in 1989 he was in
director Cameron Crowe's first movie say
anything check it out
well I had cord as a show pony I mean
that's stallion by pine walk with us and
you walk tall tall my man ditches man
okay forget Piven in fact forget
everyone else in the movie that kid is
the MVP [ __ ] man let's talk Melissa
McCarthy she is kicking ass and taking
names and Paul figs comedy spy but her
career started with a somewhat darker
turn as Nico the goth girl in the off
forgotten as it should be 2003 Kevin
Spacey filmed the life of David gale
my boyfriend took it we also got a video
it's 50 bucks cuz you can see my tits
the version without tits 35 Melissa
McCarthy also co-starred with another
star of a big summer movie Ted twos Seth
MacFarlane in the popular WB drama
Gilmore Girls here he is playing pretty
much Seth MacFarlane hey Liza that gets
me thinking maybe you and I ought to do
a little reproducing after the ceremony
clever don't be a snot shut up that's my
boyfriend Zach strangely this wasn't
Seth's only visit to Stars Hollow he
popped up a couple of years later as a
voice on Lauren Graham's answering
machine
miss Gilmore gets Bob Merriman your
mother's lawyer I'm calling about the
little matter of this lawsuit she's
involved in Lorelei don't listen to him
that's that do she was at your
graduation he's probably talking in some
voices like a super smart baby or a dog
oh thank God for caller ID sets Ted to
co-star Marc
don't call me Marky Mark Wahlberg has
also been kicking around Hollywood for a
while here he is in 1995's teen drama
fear menacing a young Reese Witherspoon
and her dad the guy from CSI could have
been different mr. wall
should have allowed nature to take its
course no it's just me her does Mark
Wahlberg's menacing voice sound exactly
like his science teacher voice from the
happening should have allowed nature to
take its course but in the end it'll be
just theory what
no ant-man is skittering into theaters
this July starring Lost's Evangeline
Lilly now before she was Kate she was a
sexy single in Canada who just wanted
you to give her a call
tonight I'm gonna do something just for
me I'm going to live links it's the best
place to meet local singles and you can
try it for free wait those are actresses
in those commercials I've been duped out
of thousands of dollars you wanted him
you got him The Terminator is coming
back for a fifth go-round played once
again by former governor and old man
Arnold Schwarzenegger here he is in the
1977 weightlifting documentary pumping
iron where he describes his enthusiasm
for lifting weights it's a satisfying to
me as the coming is you know as having
sex with a woman and coming I'm like
getting the feeling of coming in the gym
I'm getting the feeling of coming at
home I'm getting the feeling of coming
backstage when I'd pump up can he please
terminate my memory of him having said
that I'm in heaven Superman himself
Henry Cavill will be taking off the
tights and heading to the big screen
adaptation of The Man From UNCLE before
that mashup he was giving us a showdown
that we've been dying to see Superman
versus the Cenobites
in Hellraiser 8 L world
[Music]
good
it turns out Superman's weakness not
kryptonite
it's pinhead and finally we have
America's Sweetheart the star of the
movie stopping into theaters this
weekend Jurassic world's Chris Pratt
before star-lord before Parks and Rec he
was just another actor trying to make it
in television behold a nude crisp fat
plucking away at his guitar on the Fox
teen drama The OC
okay oh really nude why don't I let me
come back no wait right there I have a
gift for you my song Oh
the Bears dad Chris Pratt on the OC I
wonder if the guardians of the galaxy
will be visiting the Phantom Planet that
was a pretty sweet ride now what did we
leave out what do we miss what summer
movie star did you spot before they were
famous let us know in the comments
section below the most awesome answer
we're gonna send you a screen junkies
t-shirt thank you for watching I'm Hal
radnik hit me up on Twitter bye bye I'm
a big fan of the The Addams Family
movies Christina Ricci she's warned of
Yanis ransom you fool Tabitha green
tonight Oh death